[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm linked I'm
Rhett I use it and I'm Rhett but I just
figured this just let me say I'm Rhett
but we're keeping that sure
welcome to ear biscuits I'm still linked
know but do it but I want to do it there
I want to do it I wanted to force us to
keep the first one now you screwed up
twice yeah you see what happens
sometimes you guys get it in see this is
how sometimes it doesn't start we'll
definitely use both of those linked but
just go ahead and start it the same way
we always do
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are exploring the
question is watching sports a waste of
time I thought it was a dramatic fall
yeah what is that I forgot I forgot what
the question was they were exploring the
question well I remember what we're
talking almost said are watching sports
knows I know that is watching sports a
waste of time
see you're having a grammatical debate
with in your mind about the sports
sentence I was also also I'm still
intermittently listening to that the
podcast the Joe Rogan podcast when Ilan
musk was on and he pauses a long one he
pauses so long when he's asked a
question that I feel like it's affecting
the way that I'm beginning to think like
you asked him a question and he waits 7
seconds to say the first word in the
first words usually but he's like the
smartest man on earth well you didn't
just skip to the part where you smoked
weed no cuz I'm sitting to it it's not
this it's not it this is a tiss find it
by the Titian to somebody this time this
episode comes out this is old news Elan
musk is is has gone sideways in some
other way who knows what's up with him
by this point of an airdate so ok we
will talk about is watching sports a
waste of time I think I don't know I
think we might get into it I don't think
I don't know that we're gonna agree on
this one mm-hmm
well my answer to that question does not
impact my behavior I will go ahead and
say that well I'm not saying we're gonna
we're gonna slap each other no you don't
understand what I'm saying
you know once we get going okay that's
quite a teaser but I would like to take
a few minutes just to catch up with you
Rhett I just felt like good I just feel
like for you to ask me that all day how
I've been well we we spent our
professional mornings apart and it was I
just think it's it's a good it's a good
practice to just catch up and sit what
did I miss
well I've actually good cuz I was at
work I was here in the office I was at
work in the coffee shop okay well I
didn't know that yeah all I know is that
I got a text you'd like send me the the
the ideas you had for those songs cuz
I'm gonna work on those oh I sent them
to you I was like I'm done for the day
yeah so well as you as you might know
we're gonna be at North Carolina State
Fair on October 12th Dortmund arena
it's 7:30 p.m. if you have a ticket to
the fair you can come see us and it is
not the tour of mythicality we are doing
the tour mythicality in November but
this is a special show that's all music
and of course us trying to be funny in
between songs but we're writing a few
new songs we're writing
we're writing as many songs as we can
just because that we want to continue to
shape what our live music will look and
feel like as we potentially do that more
and specifically the thing that that I
was working on isn't even necessarily a
song it's a musical bit you know I don't
want to get into the details of it
because I want it to be a surprise for
those of you who see it it's gonna be
good but I'm very excited about it but
one can I I'm I'm sorry can I just break
in one second and say that I just wanted
to acknowledge that in the last podcast
we set up an assignment for you guys and
we're still processing those things so
part two to follow up with last week's
how we interact with YouTube as users we
asked you at the end of that last
podcast to tweet us hashtag ear biscuits
any recommend day
you have four things that you think that
we will actually enjoy on YouTube as a
platform as viewers so continue to let
us know about that and when we think
that we have gathered the information
and we have an opinion we will do the
follow up podcast so no promises as to
exactly when that will be but we will be
watching noting and we will come back so
I'll tell you what I was doing when I
when I was driving in I made a playlist
of some songs I gave you a copy of it so
we could practice in our cars singing
along cuz I mean we don't it's not like
we listen to our own music all the time
you tend to forget and I hate going to a
concert where I'm attached to a
particular song and then the artists you
can tell that they totally forgot how
the song goes and they're just like
doing it totally different I don't think
they're just doing it for their own
personal I don't like I don't love that
and if I'm gonna do it I want to do it
intentionally and if I didn't listen
back through these songs brother there'd
be a lot of new lyrics and and ways that
it was delivered so as a byproduct of
that I'm driving in and of course la
traffic I'm just sitting there people
pulling up beside me waiting to get onto
different highways as I try to make my
way into Burbank and I am singing or in
some cases rapping at the top of my
lungs like if you looked over at me
which people did is they would think
that I was nuts like I was either being
attacked by bees or I was like
belligerently having road rage at the
person in front of me because I'm like
yes you know you know you don't have to
do a full bore yes it formats in or out
of practice you know I'm saving it make
mistake okay first of all this is where
weird if how has anyone around you gonna
think that you're crazy if you don't do
that in two breath control man I'm stuck
that's the thing I'm most concerned
about I'm not concerned about
remembering lyrics or the other stuff I
talked about delivering it
in an authentic way I'm concerned about
being inch given the way that we're
gonna do parts of the show I am
concerned with my breath control my
physical health my my cardio so I'm
giving it all I got in the car yeah in
my throat I'm trying to build my throat
muscles hold on we're not performing in
Dorne Arena from a car so you're going
to be standing up potentially moving
around gyrating so you really want to do
that you need to be in a van and have
somebody else to drive you around and
you need to be standing up in the back
if I can't if I can't have enough breath
control to get this stuff out while in a
driving position I'm I'm done for I have
a bone to pick with you though because
while I was at the coffee shop which
incidentally I had sort of an awkward
interaction with the barista because he
was like getting some work done didn't
have like my backpack or whatever I was
like yep yep yeah just a little break
from the office which again I was that
was my pride speaking because I wanted
to let him know I do have it off I do
have it off as I could go to it's very
large you should see it I don't need I
don't need your coffee shop to work I'm
not one of those guys I am choosing to
work at your coffee shop and he was like
oh well what do you do for a living and
I was like oh man I'm in that
conversation and I was like well what's
the best way to explain that well given
what you just said it seems like this is
what you wanted I I make youtube videos
and then he looks at the receipt and
he's like no no no he hadn't looked at
the receipt yet he was like oh you're
you're a content creator that's how it
says his other barista spoke and I was
like yeah yeah yeah yeah we love it when
you call us that you work at the you you
like go to the YouTube space or like now
we have our own space and I'm not
bragging at this point I'm just trying
being truthful and then he was like
oh oh okay yeah he has another question
I was like yeah yeah me and my best
friend we've been working together for a
long time like this and then he looked
that's when he looks at the receipt he
was like Oh rats man late he like looked
up but I wasn't there no I wasn't above
you and I think he may be concerned
about us because it sounded like my
whole thing was a big story so sure
you've got an office and sure you're
working all the best friend is that the
so that no you have to be you know I'm
getting to that
that was just an awkward interaction
that I had the bone that I have to pick
with you is the fact that I'm sitting
there at the coffee shop actually I
think before I left to leave for the day
I ended up tweeting about I I saw the
the Twitter moment Oh about Pluto Pluto
should have been a planet all along you
should have never been Declassified and
so IIIi didn't it was a I don't think it
was a particularly funny tweet it was
just it was a legitimate observation
that you know what Pluto doesn't care
about the classification don't you wish
that you could care as little about what
people think about you
so you collude oh does we did what I
said
Pluto's I tweeted the moment and then my
comment about it was Pluto's first of
all shout out to red MC on Twitter if
you want to see this tweet in all its
glory on Twitter I can tell you about it
but if you go to the Rhett MC Twitter
let's rh e TT MC you can see exactly how
you're supposed to experience it i
tweeted Pluto's indifference to this
whole situation is enviable period
period and then I just was like that's
my tweet I don't tweet every day but you
know I was like I did some Twitter I
feel a little bit better about myself
going about my day
mmm-hmm but of course after you tweet
once you got to check back in and see
you know how people are interacting with
it and at that point I see that people
are tweeting back at me and adding you
oh you guys must be in the same place
tweeting about the same thing what
actually that would never happen because
we were in different places we both
looked at the same thing
on twitter and we both tweeted about it
the moment i tweeted independently about
Pluto
I was like man he's crazy we made us I'd
cuz I had looked at that not that we're
gonna perform this song cuz we're not
because it kind of sucks it doesn't meet
the standard we have a standard for I
don't know we had a song about Pluto
from eleven years ago about it not being
a planet anymore I'm like eleven years
later
ludos on the rebound and I just thought
it'd be funny to tweet this old video
because I thought about it and I know
most people haven't seen a shout out to
me on Twitter
yep what is your handle link Lamont okay
it's just you got to get better you
don't need me to lead you into that you
need you to say shout out to link Lamont
on Twitter and then you spell it and and
then what wait are you saying Instagram
shout out to me on Instagram - it's this
kind of it's like a Fallowfield
yeah there's a great picture of a
mountaintop one day kid from from how
many years ago one day what seven years
ago
no yeah oh it's like a fallow field my
Instagram and one day it's gonna blossom
again gonna be awesome it's like any
it's like a corpse flower it's gonna be
like be be like soybeans or like for a
forest I was from November 30th 2013
we've been told okay anyway you know
it's like us okay what is it cicada so I
tweeted about Pluto yeah my Instagram
accounts like a cicada it only comes out
every seven years I don't know how many
years on Twitter I just tweeted about
the polluter thing and then I'm I'm
looking at the comments under there and
immediately somebody's like all Rhett
Rhett also tweeted about this I'm like
crap this is gonna be weird I bet his
was a funnier so then I got so I got a
bone to pick with you
I haven't even picked my bone yet that
was just the that was just the appetizer
wakey you keep dangling this bone you're
gonna pick I've been dangling my bone
39s stop dangling your bone in now no
actually it's a I guess is your bone I'm
stopped dangling my bone and pick it I
don't know whose bone it isn't I don't
know what picking it is but I
I saw that you tweeted another tweet
that was unrelated to Pluto and it was
you took a freaking screenshot of my
text to you and made it seem like I'm
just texting pictures of myself to you
and but and the reason why I did that is
because people were talking I went
hashtag ear biscuits and I'm looking at
what people are talking about and
they're talking about the episode two
weeks ago where we were talking about
conducting relation friendships over
text right and then what we decided at
the end of that was you texted that jiff
of yourself to me we're making fun of it
you did it during the podcast and I
thought it would be fun I didn't hear
that end of the podcast let me know if
it made it to the end I think it was
maybe even after it cut off but I did
I'm looking at it on your phone okay
where's that from it just typed in
around link its me given the double
thumbs up it's like a did you do that
second to find it you did do it just to
be funny but then after that the next
day you tweeted what you were wearing to
edit and tweet
I mean you exited me yeah you texted me
and I just thought it would be funny to
make up a private text conversation but
I could have had Airy public because it
related to that I could have had tagged
ear biscuits very consoling with the
people let me okay so we text pictures
what are you upset about well I'm gonna
tell you we text pictures of what we're
wearing to different events so that we
don't end up wearing the same thing and
I was like I'm gonna send link a picture
you know I'm gonna make a funny face in
it because I send in pictures all the
time and it's just so utilitarian you
got Jesse - I was like Jesse take this
picture of me so I can send it to link
and I was like I'm gonna amuse him a
little bit so I gave you the side waist
thumbs-up which was a great applicant
you were being a friend yeah you know
it's great but you weren't be
what you did is you took a picture from
the privacy of my bathroom which had the
it had like okay okay I had like the
surface of my bathroom sink
and the floor and I look over there and
I see there's like a big old there's
like a big vat of moisturizer like a
lotion what does he do with that is he
picking his bone with that and then and
then and then there's a there's a dark
thing on the floor there's a yeah it
looks it looks it almost looks like a
sweater condom but it's just it all it
is is Hanny's no it's just a sock it
looks like a winter condom like a no
show us I yeah you have to think about
the different conclusions that people
can draw okay
well the conclusion that I tried to
study the wintertime shut up was look at
Rhett just sending after our
conversation on ear biscuits now he's
trying to be so friendly that he's
sending pictures of himself constantly
and the pendulum has swung too far
that was my tweet not without was smart
that was good branding oh thank you I'm
value continuing these conversations on
Twitter and that's my way to do it and
give the people what they want a little
candid shot of Rhett in his restroom but
I will say I was been in the truth a
little bit you know I was I was just
giving you a hard time if people
couldn't read between the lines enough
to know why you actually sent those
somebody did though I saw somebody
comment on it and they said he's just
gonna figured out he's sending link what
he's wearing because they saw I left the
text that you sent off that picture from
the red carpet at some event I don't
know what it was I can't remember but
that they were oh that he wore that and
we will do this warning for kid hitting
kidding Jim Carrey show yes but I will
say before I hit tweet I literally
zoomed in on your bathroom countertop
and looked at that moisturizer I
scrutinized it and why is this such a
big vet like it was a big vat of that
and then there was a big man there's
some other stuff up there I couldn't
tell what anything was if your body was
this big you have a giant vat of
moisturizer as well and then you just so
you know but
I spent a lot of her fusteria is
unbelievable I spent a lot of time on
that thing on the floor by your foot
that that black turd looking thing the
carpet content winter condo and I was
like zooming in right and I was I loved
it because I doing anything I scrolled
through the ambiguous
through the reactions to my tweet and
someone zoomed in on that and put like a
an arrow pointing to it was like we need
to talk about this I knew it I loved it
was it a sock I know it's a winter
condom oh okay
okay well we are actually gonna have a
conversation about I'm sorry I'm sorry I
won't hang on I will not tweet
screenshots of private text we have
sounds like a good day today okay I
won't do another I'm not gonna send you
more pictures of myself your loss
okay we're gonna continue this
conversation but first we do want to let
you know that you can grab one of these
mugs that says good luck with that good
luck with that I love this mug it it's
so snarky yet I feel like it brings me
good luck for having it it doesn't give
anyone law superstitious huh it doesn't
give anybody luck it actually gives them
the opposite I don't believe in what
you're doing
it's kind of what this mug says but I'm
still gonna be nice about it it's
comically cynical was the intention good
luck with that that is a that is the r
and ler the official mythical beast
mascot with a logo of himself on his
tank top in the colors of our Buies
Creek Elementary School which
incidentally they changed the freakin
mascot from the demons it's not the
demons anymore what yeah yeah I can't
remember I can't believe I'm just
remembering this I don't even know what
it is somebody somebody went to Boyd's
Crete school and took pictures inside
the gym and it says like Buies Creek
Knights or something like that at some
point they realized that demons this is
probably not a great mascot we got it we
got a deuce
than about this we yeah you know what
they need to change it back to the
demons we should start a public movement
you know what let's table that but let's
think about it okay this still the ad
still Lee and also get links shirt
mythical dots store you can't get my
shirt you can't just get a blank navy
he'll have to sell blanks you have to go
to the Hanes section of Walmart to get
that okay okay okay okay
when you don't shoot blanks use a carpet
winter winter winter it's not carpet
it's not made of carpet that would be
horrible what is it made of
so mythical Death Star
okay let's get support get into sports I
you know I successfully delayed us
talking about sports for 20 minutes well
I feel like I need to address this right
right up top I think I need to address
those of you who for some reason haven't
already clicked away because you're I
don't want here and talk about sports I
don't like sports this podcast this
episode of ear biscuits is for you if
you don't like sports if you do like
sports you don't have to like sports to
appreciate the conversation we're going
to have about sports and we're not
really gonna have a conversation
directly about sports we're gonna have a
conversation about the merits of
watching sports specifically being
entertained by watching and I think I
would say on television I'm not even
necessarily talking about going to
sporting events which I feel like is a
different it's a different experience I
feel like they can be lumped together
and change how I can love them together
but at least when you go to watch a
sporting event it's like if I've had
people who say I'll go to a basketball
game or I'll go to a hockey game and
kind of experience the group thing just
I'm just talking about a man like me a
man a woman anyone sitting down on a
couch just watching other people do
stuff in a completely disconnected place
is it worth it you know what what got
you thinking about this
because you I mean I know you're
anticipating that I'm gonna be in
opposition or I am definitely coming
from a different place but I want you to
tell me what got you in it well let me
first of all what I met earlier when I
got sports but this conversation yeah
but what I meant earlier when I said my
answer to that question does not dictate
my behavior or whatever I said was the
question to me is yes it isn't wasted
the answer is yes it is a waste of time
but I do it a lot and I probably will
continue to do it so I'm not gonna try
to argue necessarily I'm interested in
the psychology that keeps me going back
so I've got a little research that we'll
go into but so I'll tell you my
experience well that's it okay well then
I gotta say it's not a waste of time
okay
I just want just for the sake of a foil
here I I think it's sad for you to be so
yeah I want you to quote quantify how
into sports you are and then what I'm
gonna tell you is I think it's sad that
you're as into sports is you're asking a
question and now you're telling me my
answer is sad if you quantify your love
for sports and it is a lot I think it's
sad that you would say yes it's a waste
of time I do that doesn't go together to
me man and I think that I think you know
change your own mind by talking about us
so many things eating quantify your love
of sport even start there eating dessert
is a waste of calories but I'm gonna
keep doing it because it's fun
so okay first of all I feel like there
are two different audiences and I and
I'm so I I don't I'm super self-aware
about this so I feel like I have to
address both of them because in the
general population I'm kind of like
kinda into sports like when you take
into account like where I grew up like
when's the last time you painted any
part of your body to align with a sport
color motif never it what college once
when we
when we okay yeah when we had a new
coach herb Sendak NC State basketball
coach and before of us me and you and
Greg and Tim painted ourselves
h.e.r.b.i.e kind of just looked like a
marijuana add at the man and no one knew
what we were trying to do because he was
it was his first game coaching I think
they knew some well a lot of people
didn't when was the last time you
altered your schedule for an extended
length of time for sports this past
weekend now we're talking yeah so that's
what got me thinking about this so so I
am on the scale of people at mythical
entertainment I am on the very top end
of the spectrum with just a couple of
other people who care about sports but
in in in normal groups of people like
like okay Alex here cares about sports
he watches Michigan sports we talk about
college sports and daring cares of a
significant amount about sports but when
you take your place on that continuum
and you apply it to the greater just the
general population you're low on the
just really Maddux I feel like I'm just
average dude but I don't know and I get
the sense whenever I talk about sports
on the internet just like I did in my
little rant that I did at last season of
GMM which I really thought was gonna be
awesome and it's gonna get shared by a
lot of people and it wasn't so I still
regret that but but just like when I
burned you a little bit and that's
informing this computation when I talked
about it when I talked about it on the
internet the people who interact with me
on Twitter they seem to just not have
any idea what I'm talking about nor do
they care at all it's as if the majority
of people who comment on things that
we're a part of on the Internet do not
have a space for sports in their life
yeah it's like it's been taken up with
either us or things tangentially related
to us and we're related to the Internet
and and that I think your clarification
those who comment so people who comment
unsolicited ly is that a word
because what actually happened recently
was a couple of weeks ago we did an
episode and then in good mythical more
it was it was the good mythical more
with the Cobie episode so we're back in
the studio and we went through ugly
basketball shoes and other those of you
who are fans of us Kobe Bryant the guy
who was on that episode he was a very
good basketball player yeah and so I
made a joke about the Fab five
you know the Michigan I know man in 1991
or so I don't know what year it was
somebody out there would know but I made
a Fab five joke about the the Chris
Webber shoe and there's an extra time
out in the shoe because of the whole
time I think it looks like you have a
cheese grater on the bottom like you can
grate cheese with the side of your shoe
pretty good yeah here's the thing you
unfold that little part that says web
you get an extra time out boy you're
really searching for that one that's
like a fab for reference huh uh-huh
whether five votes actually Fab five
really there's some people don't count
him out there are some people out there
who appreciated that joke more than
anything has ever been said on this show
just for you okay and he's here well
Darren was like I get that I appreciate
that
then and I made a comment like for the
one of you out there who understands
what I'm talking about I had two or
three people who have never tweeted at
me who've never commented tweet at me
and say hey just want to let you know
that I really appreciated that that
Chris Webber joke never commented but
just letting you know so I think that
they think they were listening right now
I think there are people who are sports
fans but the the Venn diagram the
crossover between sports fans and then
people who really want to engage vocally
with us on the Internet
it's a small crossover for whatever
reason so you are going to get into some
psychology so get into first just get
into I mean you said that you you
haven't painted yourself but you have
cordoned off scheduled aspects of your
life mm-hmm and altered it for sport and
I think this is gonna blow your mind
because the sport that has consumed me
to a certain level is the
sport that most people consider by far
the most boring sport to watch golf and
not only it's just crazy this crazy
intersection how onok is it that not
only is golf from someone who owned the
outside the most boring sport you could
watch it also is by far the lengthiest
name what other sport where they play
four days in a row for four to five
hours at a time and you have to watch
all of that if you want to watch the
full event could you imagine I was a
basketball game that lasted like 15
hours and you had to watch it over the
course of Thursday Friday Saturday and
Sunday well wait though I'd like to see
that once I would like to see there's a
slugfest
I would love to I would watch that once
man I would one never-ending basketball
game like if it was the best NBA players
like if it was the NBA championship like
one year the like guys they're about to
do the what's the toss-up thing the tip
of tip-off about to do the toss up and
they're like guys I just want to tell
you before we start this is gonna last
for days you're gonna you're gonna break
for dinner there may be a weather delay
when it gets dark you're gonna sleep
you're gonna get up the next morning
you're gonna start at different times
but I would watch I will watch that once
once yeah
I mean can you imagine them all getting
so exhausted hmm but I digress
I also in the interest of digression I
wonder what the second longest match
play sport is I mean I know some tennis
matches can go
I mean record tennis matches could be
like eight hours like pro level Jakub
look up the longest match professional
tennis match another probably baseball
game that's going on for a long time
yeah before baseball can go really long
well not as long as a tennis match but
we'll come back go ahead
so you're devoting four days well let me
clarify there's a few caveats here
number one I dip eclis don't watch the
Thursday in the Friday
i watch the weekend I watch Saturday and
Sunday
so I'm and I'm also recording all of
this and then I am doing what I call
Tiger vision and there we have and
you're not watching golf I'm watching
Tiger Woods you're watching Tiger Woods
and now first of all I embody everything
that true golf fans hate because I am
that guy who only cares and I'm only
watching because Tiger Woods is in
contention again if you haven't been
following and first of all when this
comes out this will this episode will
come out all I've seen is I've seen him
play the BMW Championship but the Tour
Championship the final event of the year
will have just finished like last night
when this episode goes up so I don't
know what ended up happening I'm sure I
know and Cher I'm sure I watched it but
yes I am that guy I'm sure we'll both be
tweeting about it at the same time and I
am that guy who only cares about Tiger
Woods when it comes to golf I am a
golfer I played on the high school golf
team didn't set any records wasn't that
great
still play occasionally shepard is
currently going to golf a few times a
week so i'm kind of getting back into it
but so is Tiger there was a period of
time in which I watched back when he was
the greatest player to ever play the
game and was winning all the time it was
one of those it was sort of that Michael
Jordan LeBron James factor where
somebody begins to dominate in such a
significant way that it just intersected
with me at a time in my life where I
just really wanted to see him succeed
which was like 10 years yeah yeah well
she's crazy well it was 20 years ago and
then Wow up to about 10 years ago we're
getting some feedback on this
the Isner mallet match to the 2010
Wilmington championship took 11 hours
five minutes over three days total of
183 games Wow they had to keep coming
back I didn't realize that every days 11
hours so I have a sport thing that I
almost knew and tennis is like another
potentially boring but boring sport so
anyway but but not nearly as boring as
golf right and so and we're
constantly play yeah we're gonna get you
out we're gonna get into why some people
are living out certain things boring or
what but so I admit I am everything that
is wrong with with golf spectating
because as soon as Tiger had his whole
deal
his the whole his whole world fell apart
because of what he did and into cheating
and then he's got then he got hurt and
you just said that in a dangerous way
but we'll come back to it because that
in a dangerous way it seemed like you
just made Tiger the victim you know his
whole world fell apart I said with the
cheating he was he was responsible for
him I know I'm giving you an opportunity
to especially you know I which is an
interesting it's an interesting
interesting aspect of this because I
recognize that because there are some
people who are like okay he showed his
true colors and he was this you know
this totally deceitful guy who has no
character he proved that and it was
public and then so I'll never I'll never
pull for him again I respect that
for me it has always been and still is
just about the the athletic dominance in
this particular arena that is right that
I am personally interested in and I and
again I'm not saying I'm proud of it I'm
just saying I cannot pull myself away
from it when he came back this year yeah
ya think so you're not even if you're
not defending that you're right and
being a fan of Tiger Woods and would you
actually call yourself a fan of Tiger or
you're just I'm a fan of Tiger Woods the
athlete without a doubt but you're not
defending that choice is being righteous
or what choice the choice to to follow
him and therefore some no or no because
then it's a task I recognize how
annoying it is for all these other guys
who are out there doing incredibly well
and in the golf world and no one caring
about them for 10 years until Tiger
comes back and all of a sudden I'm
saying especially giving what what
everything I don't know everything
I just I remember vaguely pieces of it
but I'm setting that let me tell you
what what he represents to me
okay he's 42 I'll be 41 very soon
and he's got back issues specifically
you know he had the exact same injury
that I've had with the herniated disks
he had fusion surgery he's coming back
and he's competing with these guys
and he's almost won and I feel like
there's this part of him that represents
this 40-something year old guy who still
has it and can still compete and I feel
like I am pulling for myself in some
ways strictly talking about athletically
in spite of the fact that he cheated on
his wife and whatever else he did that I
may not be able to remember I'm
conveniently setting those things aside
and I recognize I'm conveniently setting
those things well I think it speaks to
the power of sport in your life that
it's not about him it's about you yeah
and and so on a brain level I mean there
is science that says that when you watch
sports you're not just you you it's a
relationship your brain interprets it as
a relationship and you're in it you're a
part of it it's you what whatever that
team is and so it's a very powerful
thing psychologically yeah that has much
less to do with I mean you may be
intimately acquainted with in the world
of football the whole concussion injury
thing and like that just not it doesn't
make sense how could you how could you
understand what what's going on with
people with with their brains and still
support it or I mean people will say the
brutality of boxing
there's something that I think you're
hitting on there that's very fascinating
that it's about it of course it's about
me it's not only this about you but
there's there's this deep ineffable
connection that that's certain people
not everybody has and so I'm when it
comes to Tiger I can see how
the the things that you rattled off very
much make it about you and it so that
starts to make sense of why you would
devote your entire weekend and and you
know I'm exaggerating a little bit cuz
so I was actually so lock and I were
watching the third round of the BMW
Championship at home on Saturday and
lock has gotten into it as well locks
played a little bit of golf we're gonna
talk a little bit about what the
research says about if you've played a
sport if you have a physical connection
and appreciation for a particular sport
it actually what's happening in your
brain is one of the reasons that you
find it not boring I could only imagine
if I hadn't know if I never play golf or
had an appreciation for what it's like
to do what they are able to do that it
would be the most boring thing I could
possibly imagine
yeah but we're sitting there watching it
and we're like we get really into it
like we're like we get up we yell we get
five you've seen how ridiculous the fans
the Tiger fans are on that if you if you
watch this for a little bit you see how
crazy these people react to golf to a
little ball going in well the thing that
I've noticed and when I look over your
shoulder because I saw you it was a
Monday and the tournament a tournament
was continuing and you were doing that
why your vision but I couldn't do
television cuz it was a livestream he
would drive the ball off the tee
that's a good good swing and then he
would all of a sudden the shot would be
on him but I would just here at first I
was like after he hits drives the ball
off the tee there multiple people are
injured that's literally what it sounded
like to me is they get so into it they
get so into it as much as any football
game it's it's it's like you pull
somebody off the front lines of like a
Gettysburg and you're amputating them it
didn't that's a little cold or something
but so and I and I've done like a
raucous I I need Tiger vision because
Tiger vision for me is I've recorded the
whole thing and I wait until I won't
catch up with live because I and I stay
off of the Internet
and then I fast-forward and I wait until
I see the red sweater or the red shirt
that's well on a Sunday and I stop and
sometimes I get it wrong and sometimes
we see a putt go in oh my
I know Tiger visions really tough I just
want a program that is just Tiger vision
is so many people would pay for Tiger
vision I know it seems like it's so anti
the sport but I just want to see what
he's doing
and then anyone who's about who's
actually competing with him and he's
relevant in comparison to him I'd like
to see them every once in a while I'm
sure they've thought about just putting
a camera there's a camera following her
the whole time right why can't you just
watch that stream it's like freaking you
all a cart some viewing they like Golf
Channel will do that sometimes where you
can follow a featured group I don't want
to follow the featured group because it
takes the feature group four hours to
play okay I want to see Tigers
highlights and see a score change but to
all back-to-back in like a 40-minute
period I mean honestly how much time are
we talking about he's on screen doing
his thing it's got to be less than an
hour I think you're describing
SportsCenter but it's not the same cuz I
don't feel like just watching the
highlights do it because I don't know I
psychosis man I'm not saying it's
healthy and I haven't even gotten to
talk about NC State sports well let
let's skip to that then okay the other
thing that's happening is this freakin
football season again and I don't care
about NFL football i watch I'm from the
south man we watched college football
and yeah there's Carolina Panthers but
they didn't really they weren't around
when I was growing up and plus they're
in Charlotte and that's a Carolina town
and we're in C state I I don't care who
cares right I care about NC State sports
I care about the football team and so I
have made it a point to find where the
games gonna be being broadcast and then
I do watch that mostly in real time
sometimes I'll like skip the first half
and kind of catch up but I'd why
rearrange why so what I would say I
don't so what I would say well the
reason that I watch it is because I can
I tell you the reasons why I don't
because this be really quick because
they lose a lot more than they win and I
experienced so much disappointment when
I was close to it ie in college and
going to some games and then getting out
of college for the next few years
trying to maintain my allegiance and it
just heartbreak that's that's the
Wolfpack mo I don't believe that that's
why you don't watch plus and plus I'm
just I'm no longer that into it
I just got other it's it's definitely
not fun to watch and and lose much more
than when it's just not but okay yep but
that second part of the equation is not
true witness e state football so we're
actually pretty good at football oh
really I feel like if I started watching
we start losing again that's called
sport superstition which is a totally
different thing we can get into well I
definitely believe in that so because
yes but you don't have to refute me just
keep going no yeah that would be what
what I would say if you were watching
Carolina football this year Carolina is
the worst team in ACC UEC you beat them
by 20 points maybe I should start
watching okay I mean right so it isn't
about that for innocent for me it's
definitely not about the fact that we're
winning or that we're losing I gave up
at a time when that was the case for me
it is about I have placed some portion
of my own self-worth on the performance
of the the the sports that I watch I
don't watch sports disconnected there
are some people are like I just show me
a college basketball game just show me
you show me a sport I don't care I won't
watch a random basketball game I won't
watch like even when March Madness is
around it's like every once in a while
I'll get into like following a team but
what I have really connected with is NC
State sports and then a few random
athletes like Tiger Woods usually
somebody who's like dominant in their in
their sport like LeBron James which
we'll talk about how he's complicated
things and coming to Los Angeles you
sure you don't mean Ginobili exactly so
but with NC State I and interestingly so
what I would have said before I looked
at the research is that there's a
portion of my self-image and self-esteem
that is tied into the performance of
these things that I have some I've
either made an association like with
Tiger Woods I have no association with
him at all but
maybe's made an identification about the
same age tobacco that an inci state it's
where I went to school I mean if that
comes up in conversations now with
people I mean on any give weekly basis
you'll probably mention that you went to
North Carolina State I've actually found
that to be true in myself I would assume
that then having a connection to the
sports program and especially in success
there's like oh it's you know you start
to feel better about that association
and it will affect my day oh so if if
and that's why Jesse's always like I
hope that if you're gonna choose to
watch them I hope they win because I
know how it will make you will be after
this game and I'm sure anyone who's
actually a sports fan could very much
relate to this is it logical no is it
something I'm proud of
no did I have any impact on the outcome
of the game that happened probably in
the past because I'm watching a
recording of it on the other side of the
the nation no I didn't have any impact
on it but yet I still receive personal
self esteem boosts by watching them win
an dissociating with them no let me just
talk a little bit about what the science
says because it was pretty pretty
fascinating okay because my theory is
that it has to do with your upbringing
III think knowing about you and about me
I trace it back to that so definitely
that's that that's what entered yeah
because if you go back my dad was was
and is a huge sports fan again mostly
college very much Georgia football like
he is he watches all sports but like the
thing he's passionate about the thing
that he has tied his self-esteem to is
Georgia football completely his
self-esteem is completely tied to when
it comes to sport and he takes it much
he takes it harder than I do like he
will be and I remember this growing up
like if they won it was it was great if
they lost he was and if the good thing
is is that Georgia has been you know
traditionally very good at football so
if you're gonna tie your self-esteem to
one
in one sports safe Georgia football is
you know it's not quite like Alabama but
it's pretty good and so but I but
definitely I remember the way that we
experienced sports and we would find it
in anything I remember watching really
competitive tennis matches and golf and
back when support there was no sports
channel there was no ESPN it so the
major sports championships were on
network television everybody watched
them in real time and you watch them
with your family and my dad and my
brother and I would sit there and we
would watch these things just intently
like everybody would know impotant
vivid memories of like Boris Becker
playing tennis you know I'm saying like
yes and caring so much about it and
identifying with it so it was in my
household so it was ingrained in me in
that way you know as far as the nurture
side and for me it was not right so no
yeah and you don't make an active
decision to tie your self-esteem in any
capacity to these things but it happens
I think that's what probably what you're
gonna get at because if I choose my
argument is is it a waste of time it's
not only a waste of time it's a waste of
emotional energy that like just hike
just go on a hike like connect with
nature bring people along that you love
you know and listen I don't feel good
after I do it so let me let me also
clarify that even if it sounds like an
addiction even if the team wins when I
realized that I've been laying there
watching a man in a red sweater hit a
little white ball for hours in
meticulously fast-forwarding and then
backing up when I see too much and
trying to erase it from my memory I
don't feel good about myself when that
time is over I just don't and I don't
feel great maybe it's the color red
because NC State and Tiger Woods I don't
know where's incidentally that is
something the research shows is that
people sports teams who wear red are
more feared but that has not really
really really come into play with NC
State so well maybe times were changing
them so if this if if more scientists
like sports
then all sports teams will be hues of
red right goodness scientists have
better things to do than yeah well okay
speaking of scientists now when you
begin to look at what scientists say
about the psychology of sports fandom
you realize that there's not a whole lot
of people who are thinking about this
there hasn't been an incredible amount
of research devoted to this no funding
nobody's getting grants to study fan
psychology they already know how to make
a lot of money off of it people who are
making money but there is a guy so I
read this article from the Columbia
Journalism Review by a guy named Eric
Simons and he talked to a guy named
Daniel Juan might be when is w a n n
he's at Murray State and this guy is the
he's described but most of his
colleagues as far and away the leading
sports fan psychologists in North
America in Murray State in Kentucky
so and he he has no grant funding but he
his specialty is studying this and like
if you go to his Murray State like
professor page it says in particular I
am interested in the causes and
consequences of sport team
identification ie the extent to which a
fan feels a psychological connection to
a team which is incidentally exactly
what he says to his barista when he
works from the coffee what do you do for
a living well let's see how I can
explain this go to Murray State
II D you he does what now I was thinking
to my joke so hard I didn't actually
listen to he basically he studies why
people watch sports and okay and he is
I'd like to study why he studies that so
he according to Eric Simon's when he
talked to Daniel professor Juan he said
there are eight reasons let me just go
through these people like sports because
they get self-esteem benefits from it
also because some people have money on
it because their boyfriend or girlfriend
or family member like sports hmm because
it's exciting okay
it is exciting I mean I've experienced
the excitement of being at a game and
something thrilling happens and you're
there with people you know and I don't
know not everyone's vomiting because
it's aesthetically pleasing
because like they see it early pleasing
yeah hmm because like the theater it is
a venue for emotional expression because
they need an escape from real world
troubles well and I think those last two
are very much like yeah I just don't
think it's fair to pick being a sports
fan apart if you're not willing to pick
being a movie fan of partly you're gonna
waste two or three hours are you watch
Wyatt Earp that's three hours man
right exactly wider what kind of jerk
are you man what are you doing watching
Wyatt Earp again yeah three hours you
could say the same you could say the
same thing about a lot of things
including every single thing that we put
on the internet for people to enjoy
including this very conversation meta
much and finally because it provides a
sense of belonging connection to a wider
world so we're to the tribalism right
okay so is that it so okay so
interestingly speaking directly to that
Eric says in his article that a popular
theory is that sports are a substitute
for tribal warfare and which is what
I've always thought it's what I said in
my little rant that was not as awesome
as I thought it was he does not agree
with this he says there's no evidence
but there's an article that I found in
Psychology Today which says exactly the
same thing an evolutionary biologist
says that essentially this is this is
tribe or tribal warfare that has become
it's a safe modern-day expression of it
and that's why we identify with it to
the degree that we do we've evolved to
survive I mean evolution is survival of
the fittest as an aspect of it so it's
but there's already a fight you like to
buy emotionally buy emotionally sourced
associate you're socially supporting and
associating yourself with a winning
tribe you are propagating your own DNA
essentially that makes sense to me I
still believe that that's an aspect of
it depends on what happens after the
game but the most interesting thing that
I found that I'd never heard of before
is this something called mirror neurons
and so basically simply stated about one
fifth of the neurons that fire
in the pre mortar I cannot speak today
you're not even saying neurons right
neurons that's nice a neurons neurons
neurons neurons neurons neurons neurons
yeah there's an e in it I'm saying
neurons Nia rods you just want me say
neurons are so boring it's like golf
about one fifth of the neurons that fire
in the premotor cortex when we perform
an action say like kicking a ball
hitting a golf ball also fire at the
sight of somebody else performing that
action so they did an experiment and
this is all this isn't an article that
was linked to by that first article
where they had three different groups of
people watch guys shoot basketball
free-throws simple action there were
guys who played basketball in the first
group second group were expert Watchers
like sports writers and then the third
group were students at this university I
think was in Italy who had never played
basketball and the players and the
riders had areas of their brains
activated related to the motions of
shooting a free throw
while the non sporty students did not
and this is also true when people just
read about sports so hearing about
sports actor activates the same parts of
the brain that it would take to play
those sports and that's why if you have
experience with a specific sport again
golf is something that is incredibly
difficult to master not just a master it
is incredibly difficult to become a non
embarrassing golfer right it but to
complete your thought it's impossible to
watch having never played and begin to
even start to appreciate that and this
is true from me in the way that I now
appreciate watching ninja play for
tonight I think I talked about this at
some point I never unjust understood
let's play I'm not a gamer but because
my son was playing fortnight and I tried
for a little bit to play fortnight again
the self-esteem thing I then can now sit
and I and I don't seek out ninjas vid
but like I follow him on Instagram and
he'll do these little clips and instead
of just passing over them mindlessly now
I watch them and I'm like today I
understand how first of all I have a
point of reference for the physical
space he's in because I've been there
and I played the game but I can also
appreciate how amazing he is at what he
does and I could see myself sitting down
and watching it for an extended period
of time
because I put myself in those shoes so
for me that continues to be a big part
of it now I've never played football but
I've played lots of sports and I'm
really into sports and I'm really into
competitive things and so I your so you
book you become much closer to
identifying with what it would feel like
to you know to be tackled right and
mortuus I bet it would hurt my back hey
you know I again this this supports my
theory which means I love it because you
know you even if you didn't play
football
your dad was obsessed with it and
Georgia football so you had a bond you
were taught how to experience football
as a spectator there's somebody who was
a like the sports writer in in in the
study right her dad taught you how to
watch it and he created an environment
where memories were made that you
subconsciously pull on all that and then
you pet and you eat you past that
experience along the lock and I do not
have that experience with Lincoln I mean
we started going to clippers and be a
basketball games because it was your
idea and I was like you know what I want
to get in on this I think Lincoln's into
plain NBA live he's really into
basketball now 2k because he started
playing video games and he started
playing it in the real world and we went
to Clippers games and I wanted to foster
something in him that I didn't have and
I'm glad to say that like he plays
basketball multiple times a week and of
course locks very into it but I'm trying
to remember our point going to the I
can't
a point going to the Clippers games it
was something about that well it's the
connection and I didn't have that
connect I I didn't have enough of that
connection and it was hard for me to
foster it at that point and when I make
that connection now here's this is my
and I did and even if we go a little bit
over our typical time I do want to talk
about LeBron coming to the Lakers
because I know we have opinions about
that okay yeah yeah yeah but
specifically when I watch sports with
Locke mm-hmm or when I talk about sports
with my dad which does continue to be a
point of connection the majority of the
point of connection that I have with my
dad those points it doesn't feel like a
waste and I said that that was my
closing line and the rant was something
about it gives me something to text my
dad about well and you might say from a
psychological perspective so you don't
think it's a waste you shouldn't need
this in order to connect with somebody
you should connect with somebody on
something more personal that you share
between the two of you that's more
direct and that's um you know
intermediary thing but the fact is when
I sit there and watch tiger or NC State
by myself which ends up happening
Locke's doing a bunch of stuff on the
weekend it those points it feels like a
waste when he's there with me and we're
watching it together we're like really
getting into it and we in and the
trifecta is we're watching it they win
and he's there you know they'll never
forget that that doesn't feel like a
waste we don't is so crazy it gets it's
it's in it's in at that point triple
overtime it's like going on a nature
hike it's like going on a backpacking
trip and like having a near-death
experience but then making it through
and you're grabbing each other by the
collar and you're like we made it hey
man this is a haines special don't
somebody just grabbing it like that I
got it it's just $3.00 we made it
yeah so I think now that I've thought
through this I think my theory my my my
answer to the question is if it calls if
your connection to the sport based on
something that may ultimately be
unhealthy or something
deep in your reptilian brain if that
causes you to then connect with somebody
in the here and the now it's not a waste
but me just sitting there individually
enjoying it like a junkie and just Tiger
vision oh there is
oh it's chipping it in don't make me
wait if that is my experience
then I feel like it's a waste but here's
the thing
sometimes I'll watch it and then like
okay so Locke was in North Carolina
recently Tigers playing and he and he
calls me he's like dead you see Tiger
you see what he did and we talked about
it but and so I had a point of
connection with my son okay he was not a
waste can we really get to the point
though how do you feel how do you feel
about Andre Agassi when he went bald I'm
just joking do you really think that you
have to justify being a sports fan yes
with a connection with your son I do
feel that way yeah I do
I do feel that way because I so you
can't watch a movie alone no I'm never
gonna watch a movie alone again no I
just think that the Wyatt Earp man three
hours alone is good cinema that's a good
point it's a very good point but I don't
I think I I think it I I don't know I
think they I think you got to go all the
way and you got to defend it as just a
form of recrea there's there a
difference here's the difference when I
enter into a movie I'm doing it under
the with the understanding that this is
just for me to be entertained that is
not why any sports fan watches sports do
you think sports fans non-sports fans
think that sports fans watch sports to
be entertained they are wrong I am wrong
okay
sports fans watch sports because they
can't help themselves because of the
self esteem boosts that we're talking
about in this identification with it now
I'm not saying some
things are not in play when you're
watching a movie but last point is to me
I at least begin to understand and I'd
maybe I maybe I pity you you've got this
you've been you've been built you've
experienced sports directly and
indirectly within the by playing them
whether you're with your dad growing up
lots of other things it's it's a part of
like watching it is some magical
connection that I do not have because
Sports was only associated with anxiety
when I participated so for me I don't
feel anxiety well I do feel some anxiety
when I watch but I ultimately I just
don't connect it's like I don't get it
you know it's very much it's a
biological language that you're having
with this thing yeah well I don't
disagree with that but what I'm saying
is I don't feel like it's the same thing
as watching a movie because when I go
into a movie I'm going into it
completely selfishly to be entertained
and yeah it's cool to do that with
somebody but I could do that on my own
but I'm watching sports I'm not choosing
to do it to be entertained because if it
was about being entertained then you
could substitute someone who wasn't
Tiger Woods which happens which has
happened every single weekend this year
who in that instance is better than him
and I don't want to watch I don't want
to watch Bryson shambo vision you know
what I'm saying I could care less about
that
he's better than Tiger right now but I
don't wanna watch him it's not about
being entertained
it's about this psychological connection
to something I'm hoping that someone can
accomplish for me that benefits me in
some way that I don't even I still
understand I think you're describing
actually and don't sell that short I
think you could spin it the other way
and you could then be building your case
that this is a deeper form of
entertainment for you a deeper form of
connected recreation in a in the same
way that someone may describe ten years
down the road how much more advanced
virtual reality will be
you don't understand when I'm in it it
is me what I do think we connect with
entertainment that is taps into our
empathy you know it when you can relate
to a character and you are putting
yourself in the shoes of a character and
you want them to win that is how you
enjoy the best stories I just I agree
with that don't think your landing point
should be that you should Slough this
thing off and like well as long as I do
it with my son it's a legitimate it's
more than just a form of entertainment
that feels like I need I actually should
be going to therapy for what there's
tangible but the reason I think that I
could do that is because there's
tangible benefit in that approach there
would be tangible benefit I mean if I
took I get out of my life apart from the
connection that I made with other loved
ones
oh well restate that I'm saying that if
I sat down with my therapist I haven't
discussed this with my therapist but if
I said I explained all this and he was
like well I think you should watch
sports with your son but I don't think
you should watch it by yourself then I
would be like I understand the logic
behind that decision and I can't dispute
that I don't I mean it's not my place to
tell you because I'm also says I'm
already watching movies in television
I'm just fighting I'm fighting on behalf
of of sports fans to not at the end of
this conversation have made where they
come from illegitimate or dirty or
something that needs to be fixed okay
because hey I think it's stupid but you
my friend have got a champion this we
got to got to do it for them you got oh
well here's what I'll say if you if you
enjoy these thing you don't think it's
too if I don't show these things by
yourself ice if you enjoy these things
yeah because you're like the cable news
producer that wants there to be two
opposing American cable news you're like
a fox news producer right now you don't
have to have two different opinions but
we can't we can because what I am gonna
say right now is I'm actually I'm
actually thinking about that thin slice
of sports fan that is listening maybe
it's 50%
and I I think you've I think I've
learned things I think you've brought
things to light that not only made me
empathize but it's just like you know
what I kind of envy that deeper
connection you know I don't have it
because of things those things were
missing from my upbringing so I start to
fill I actually feel jealous so I don't
I'm starting to think maybe you don't
have to defend yourself you're just like
it's actually a magical connection but
if I don't feel good after I do it then
I think I could that's probably a
problem so now you can take an
experience you have while watching
sports alone and then connect with
someone else after the fact that's what
happens all the time oh you're a
Pittsburgh fan too and then you're into
a conversation so I'm just saying if it
if it benefits relationships then I see
direct social benefit but I also
recognize that in some ways we're just
tapping into some deeper something in
our brains that doesn't necessarily need
to be fostered my opinion is not going
to change anybody's behavior
I don't think sports are not going away
anytime soon
with with all the changes in the
landscape let's just talk briefly about
LeBron coming to the Lakers and how we
think about that because we haven't
discussed it in detail but I know that
we have different perspectives on this
so as Linc said we we have been and I am
continue to be a Clippers fan a lot of
people are like oh you're a Clippers fan
because of when you moved to Los Angeles
I am a Clippers fan for a number of
reasons let me state them very quickly
the Lakers to me have always seemed like
the Carolina of the NBA right there's
people who like them and wear their
jerseys just because they have a winning
tradition and so I as an NC State fan I
despised UNC we have talked about this
repeatedly you go all around the world
and you see people have no affiliation
with the University who just like to
wear the jersey and they're all about
their tradition and not in all the
winning that they've done and it just
makes me sick right yeah sure I'm
jealous but when I moved here to Los
Angeles I was like I don't want to be a
Lakers fan because it feels
dirty it feels like just getting into
some sort of tradition that I'm not a
part of at the time Vinny Del Negro
former NC State Wolfpack star was the
coach of the Clippers and I was like
perfect opportunity I can be a Clippers
fan so a lot of things lined up turns
out right after that the Clippers were
just starting to get good and then they
became way better than the Lakers and
then of course what happened recently
but he didn't he did not remain the
coach no Doc Rivers became the coach and
they've had the Clippers had a little
run but now basically everything fell
apart they had a run the year that was
two years ago that we had season tickets
yeah and things kind of fell apart for
them and who knows what's happening
we're in a rebuilding phase meanwhile
LeBron comes to the Lakers and let me
just say quickly my opinion on LeBron is
I think he's great I think he's a great
person I think he said I think he's
probably the best player to ever play
the game and I tend to gravitate towards
people who are dominant and in their
sport and so I've been a Cleveland fan
simply because LeBron because I want to
see him win wherever he goes so you you
like tiger same exact print me well at
least as far as the excellence goes you
mean you can't you can't deny that I
mean but but unlike Tiger there are
people who do but unlike my mom's
husband Louis last time he came out here
we were I picked him up in the airport
and I don't know how we got on LeBron
because he hadn't this was before he he
said he was coming to the Lakers he said
that in his heyday Lewis said he could
take LeBron I don't know why I don't
know how he thought well it's just crazy
to me I thought he told you that if he
if all of a sudden he could inhabit
LeBrons body that he could be a better
player I think he said something about
like the winning mindset or something
yeah we talked about how he's a ball hog
and he's not a team player okay well
here's his thing I'll say about LeBron
is those people who don't like LeBron
that doesn't apply to tiger at least we
don't know about the specific details of
LeBrons life but it appears that he has
been a faithful
husband an incredible father and done
all the stuff for his community and it's
been very outspoken about a lot of
things and so it seems like the
character is is is there as well so
there's a lot of reasons to pull for
LeBron right now he's coming to Los
Angeles and boy this guy I'm mad I'm mad
about it because I have too much pride
to become a Lakers fan I like LeBron but
I want him to lose I want him to lose
badly because now I can still be a
LeBron fan personally but my hate for
the Lakers in that whole tradition you
don't gonna Oh it lays gonna overpower
you hate winners because we were losers
nope I'm sorry man and you know what I'm
I just I'm tired of losing I was oh so
you're gonna bandwagon that's what
you're gonna how we're so gonna bad way
I got season tickets to the Clippers and
you know what it was a lot of fun and it
just wasn't quite enough to like bacon
allegiance like I was all in like I even
knew the name of that guy who came off
the bench the big guy who would shoot
threes moe that's his name that's what I
was like but Moe in I would say things
like that like we need we need some moe
yeah remember him yeah I do yeah he's
playing for somebody else now he was an
allegiance
he had no allegiance to the Clippers
yeah well if the Lakers in LeBron had
it's a Laker leave what the Lakers want
to pay me a hundred million dollars to
root for him
I will do it okay I just didn't you know
I I'm not I'm not I don't have an
allegiance to the Clippers it was too
much I we had a lot of fun but we bought
too many tickets and then we didn't we
didn't go to all the games it was too
much hmm and they didn't win it was a
disappointment at the end and I was
still I had just hadn't fully committed
and I got I got burned man but that's
not how you know I'm talking about how
we make decisions I'm not gonna buy
Lakers season tickets but if I'm gonna
go to again
and I think it probably needs to be the
one that LeBron is playing it here's the
things by the way I was in tickets and
when LeBron came from the Cavs to play
the Clipper he set out he sat out he
wasn't it he sat the freak out it was
like one of the only reasons we were
excited about season tickets and then he
set out and Kyrie set out that game as
well okay I to wrap this up I will go to
a Lakers game with you I'm not pulling
for them well yeah I didn't invite you
okay I don't want it in a different
section I don't want you to are you
gonna like root for them I'm not I will
I will go and it will be it will be pure
entertainment to just be able to see
LeBron and that's all I'm giving it
basketball right now it's just I'm going
to watch it like a movie because you
know what I kept score for the girls
middle school basketball team that's my
only connection man when we went to the
I watched like half the season and then
we take you're like keeping score in
your head we take our friend Reba
and he's like explaining what a
triple-double is and I realized I didn't
even know that was indicated on me like
I could look at that score I did I
realized I'd it wasn't even in in
enjoying the game it's not I'm gonna go
watch LeBron just like some Fairweather
do but I'm not a fan of the Lakers
either I just give up okay good as long
as you're not a Lakers fan dinner boy he
is something put him in a Western boy
he's great is he a Lakers fan is that is
that was that your callback it was a
Wyatt Earp callback yeah remember we
watched that together yeah yeah I think
it was his best performance it's long
boy he's horrible in Field of Dreams I
tried to enjoy that okay I don't know if
we come to anything so the Brawn thing
you can't do it because I'm not gonna be
a Lakers fan
I don't you're a loser man if if the
Clippers leave Los Angeles
I'll have it I will reconsider if it
wasn't for what you just said everybody
you could have just been a Lakers fan no
cuz people know that I'm a Clippers fan
people don't know enough people no I'm
not I just I don't do
I don't flip man I'm not a flipper I'm
not gonna do that yeah I'm a loser I'd
rather be a consistent looser than a
flippin winner a fair-weather live
winner yeah you can always be a winner
you just pick that you just see who the
best team is in your route for them
listen but I I do agree that I can't
just say I'm a Lakers fan I can't do
that right you're screwed you're screwed
I'm out okay you're out for good but
we're gonna go to a game oh yeah I do
feel like our allegiance to what either
the Chargers of the Rams is still up for
grabs even though I did go to Rams game
and I bought a hat we should get to two
years ago yeah you tried that but then
the they came the Chargers came in
Phillip Rivers is the quarterback NC
State grad so I don't know we should get
to friends we should go to a Lakers game
we should paint our chests be ro n and
then when somebody goes to the bathroom
we're either gonna be bro or rod like is
there is there a rod on the Lakers look
at the R&B R&B yeah any way you slice it
anybody goes to the restroom only one at
a time
what's that our Amiga we're still
something we're either run R&B or bros
or if two of us go were just like pound
is if I need a diagram to follow this
now okay well there you have it we
talked about sports no that was the
LeBron and you just said Bron got it
yeah there's no okay if you're still
listening thank you for doing that
hashtag air biscuit so let us know what
we should watch on YouTube but or talk
to us about what we just talked about we
value that back and forth yeah in fact
just this past week when you guys
started talking about the texting
conversation a lot of people took issue
with some of the conclusions we came to
in that particular episode to and then
began to explain how texting had been so
instrumental in their own personal
communication and I don't know what kind
of it opened my eyes I also tweeted
about that mm-hm
some of you talked about how you've got
a lot of anxiety around just normal
face-to-face communication and texting
allows you to be able to do that and so
I totally get that I still stand by the
whole idea of texting and face-to-face
communication being used together being
the most effective way but but it can go
a lot further and we have first realized
yes share this episode with somebody who
loves sports or hate sports or is
anywhere in between that's everybody
exactly talk at you next week
[Music]